restrictions
well let's try to work through some of
that now with professor sir david
spiegelhalter who is a leading
statistician possibly the leading
statistician based at the university of
cambridge and the author of covid
by numbers good morning uh sir david
good morning good morning now we're
hearing about a large number uh range of
possible scenarios for the spread and
impact of omicron um it's pretty
confusing i think for most people and it
ranges from
a widespread but relatively mild in
disease to a devastating
um wave that could overwhelm the nhs can
you just start by uh with the numbers
roughly how many cases do you think we
have right now
okay the first thing is to distinguish
between people who are getting infected
and people who then become cases
because the data we see every day are
just the people who got got ill they've
got symptoms they've gone along got a
pcr test they've gone on to the system
and they've been recorded as a positive
case and those are running and you know
yesterday they went down a bit to 90 000
but we shouldn't take too much notice of
those exact numbers and it depends so
much on who on whether people get
symptoms whether they decide to get
tested
and labs are going to get very stretched
and so um
they actually only give a very crude
idea of what the infection rate was
i'm sorry um about four days before and
i think um there's no doubt that um you
know we are getting hundreds of
thousands of infections every day now
and the majority of them will be
overcrowded and i think there's no doubt
about that at all
what the consequences of that is is a
bit more tricky but one thing we can be
absolutely sure
now about the consequences are purely of
becoming a case
you know because then you're supposed to
isolate for 10 days and um and that's
going to cause is causing already and
will cause even more massive disruption
and that's nothing to do with whether
how ill people get in hospitalizations
we just know that there's going to be
huge disruption over over the you know
next weeks and months
do you think um well first of all let's
do a bit of range finding um
do you think that uh the likely rate of
hospitalizations
given all that is going to be
greater or
less fewer lesser than with last year's
delta wave
now it could be could be greater it
could be lesser now i know this it
sounds like i'm completely sitting on
the fence and that's because i'm sitting
on the fence because all the modelling
says we don't know um the the suggestion
is uh you had this discussion just now
with mark walput about the range of
scenarios that are explored well one of
those scenarios that has been modeled is
just to stick with plan b and not to
bring in any new interventions at all
and the models then suggest that
hospitalization would go uh you know
pretty confident they're going to go
above 3000 a day well that's still less
than it was last winter so um even if we
don't do anything more and you know they
could be better than last winter and but
and if we did do things uh you know
bring in other other sort of
restrictions then that could be reduced
but enormous uncertainty about those
numbers there's so much we don't know
one of them
we are finding out information now from
london where hospitalizations are going
up and one of the very interesting
things is that um if you look at the uh
the new cases the new hospitalizations
over and above what they have been over
the last few months um around about half
of those are actually people who
admitted with something else and then
were found to have covered probably the
omicron
variant and so
that suggests that if you've got a
population where a huge number are
getting infected then they'll might go
to hospital something else but then they
found have covered and so they have to
be treated you know as they've got
covered which of course is a huge drain
on resources so um
just having a high level of infection
itself
causes this huge um uh you know stress
on resources even if people are not
getting that ill
so
you're thinking that even if as
people keep saying
the south african data and i'd be
interested in your view about that uh is
suggesting that it might be minor even
with that we could still face not just
because of the numbers uh but because of
the phenomena you've just described
an overwhelming pressure on the nhs
could do and it could be um you know it
could be manageable even with sticking
with the with the um um the uh situation
at the moment i mean it it very much
depends
on
you know there is so much uncertainty
and so what does one do in terms of the
action and i'm certainly not going to
suggest any policy whatsoever um is that
um you know just how cautious does one
want to be but as mark warport said one
of the crucial things is you can't wait
to find out we can't wait for
hospitalizations to go through the roof
before we do something about it because
by then it's too late and in fact what
happens by the end of the new year by
the end of this year is pretty well
built in now there's almost pretty well
nothing we can do about it and boosters
won't have a big effect on it and we're
going to be running hospitalizations
will be up it's estimated between a
thousand and two thousand a day and that
is going to happen whatever we do so the
crucial thing is you know when we go
further into the new year um
what's what's that peak going to be can
we delay it can we flatten it and um we
will know more you know we're learning
more every day but in the same case
every day we delay
we'll have a bigger impact further on
now i'm glad i'm not having to make
those decisions um because they are
extremely difficult ones because indeed
forgive me
you say that every day makes a
difference uh everybody now i think is
beginning to understand what the word
exponential means doubling and so on
doubling every day and so on
if you had a free hand what signal would
you be looking for to see that we needed
to take
uh stricter
more severe measures greater
restrictions what what what signal in
the data would you be looking for oh i
think looking at what everyone else
looks at i mean we would love to know
exactly how many people are being
infected and and
we will find that out but a bit with
rather a delay when we do a proper
infection survey which is going on all
the time but it means there's about a
week's delay before we hear about what
the results are and we have to just work
with the data we've got because we don't
see when the virus is transmitted and we
don't see exactly how you know why
people get particularly ill or whatever
we have to infer it and that's what
stats is about i suppose trying to work
out what's going on from the little
globe bits of information that we
actually find which are deeply imperfect
and that that i think is is inevitable
and
yeah i i think
one of the things the other thing is to
actually look outside this country and
see what's happening
for example in europe pollen's just
locked down over christmas with
something that our government is
extremely reluctant to bring in measures
before christmas um but uh it's going to
be you know austria and germany for
example have just managed to control
their huge delta peak it's come down
their death rates are still you know at
least double what they are in the uk
and then omicron's going to hit them uh
it's going to be very very tough for
these countries and and uh you know
we're not in a great situation but
actually with our vaccine rollout our
coverage of boosters is extremely good
you know it should have been better we
should have done a huge amount more
during the autumn i think but um it's
getting better all the time and so we're
actually comparatively in uh somewhat
better situation than many many other
countries the other thing is that sorry
sorry uh uh professor spiegelhalter uh i
think we've run out of time
unfortunately but uh thank you very much
uh for joining us this morning
thank you